>>> THIS WEEK'S "48 HOURS"
INVESTIGATES THE DEATH OF AN
INDIANA MAN AND THE STRANGE
EXPLANATION THAT INVESTIGATORS
HAD NEVER HEARD BEFORE.
DANI GREEN TOLD FRIENDS AND
FAMILY THAT HER EX-HUSBAND, RAY,
WAS KILLED BY THE FAMILY'S
GERMAN SHEPHERD.
WHEN POLICE VISITED THEIR HOME,
THEY FOUND NO SIGNS OF HIM OR
THEIR DOG.
"48 HOURS" CORRESPONDENT PETER
VAN SANT LOOKS INTO RAY GREEN'S
DEATH.
>> Reporter: IN MAY, 2014,
POLICE WERE CALLED TO THIS
REMOTE PROPERTY IN DILLSBORO,
INDIANA, THE HOME OF RAY AND
DANI GREEN.
DANI TOLD FAMILY AND FRIENDS
THAT JAZZY, THE COUPLE'S PET,
HAD ATTACKED RAY.
>> DANI SAID THAT HER DOG KILLED
RAY.
>> Reporter: THE STRANGE STORY
DIDN'T SIT RIGHT WITH FRIEND
KAREN AUCLAIR SHARON MEIERAN.
>> ANIMALS LIKE HIM.
HOW CAN A DOG KILL HIM?
>> Reporter: TRACEY, RAY'S
DAUGHTER FROM ANOTHER MARRIAGE,
SAID HE HAD A SPECIAL WAY WITH
ALL KINDS OF ANIMALS.
>> MY DAD WAS A REAL COWBOY.
>> Reporter: RAY WAS A RENOWNED
HORSE BREEDER AND TRAINER, A
POWERFUL MAN, HE ONCE TRAPPED A
12-FOOT ALLIGATOR WITH HIS BARE
HANDS.
DANI WAS EXPERIENCED IN HANDLING
HORSES, AS WELL.
>> SHE HAD GOALS OF BECOMING AN
OLYMPIC EQUESTIRIAN.
>> Reporter: WHEN POLICE
ARRIVED, NEITHER RAY NOR DANI
COULD BE SEEN.
DANI THEN GAVE AN ENTIRELY
DIFFERENT STORY SAYING RAY, WHO
SOMETIMES WORKED AS A TRUCK
DRIVER, WAS OUT ON THE ROAD.
>> THE PROBLEM WITH THAT, THERE
WAS A BIG TRUCK ON THE PROPERTY.
THE OFFICERS WERE SUSPICIOUS
THAT SOMETHING WAS UP.
SO THE OFFICERS PINGED HIS
PHONE.
AND HIS PHONE CAME BACK TO THAT
PETE OF PROPERTY.
>> Reporter: DETECTIVE TOM
BAXTER SAYS DANI TOLD POLICE
THEY COULD LOOK FOR RAY ANYWHERE
THEY WISHED.
WITH ONE EXCEPTION --
>> SHE SAID, YOU CAN SEARCH
ANYWHERE YOU WANT EXCEPT FOR
THAT BOX.
>> THAT IS A HECK OF A TEASE.
PETER VAN SANT JOINS US NOW.
GOOD MORNING.
WHAT WAS IN THAT BOX?
>> WELL, SADLY THE BODY OF
COWBOY RAY GREEN WAS INSIDE THAT
BOX.
HE HAD BEEN SHOT TEN TIMES WHICH
OBVIOUSLY IS SOMETHING A DOG
COULD NOT DO.
INVESTIGATORS BELIEVED HIS BODY
HAD BEEN IN THAT BOX FOR ABOUT
TWO DAYS.
>> WHAT HAPPENED TO THE FAMILY
DOG?
>> JAZZY THE GERMAN SHEPHERD
WHICH, BY THE WAY, WAS A MILD,
LOVING DOG, WAS NEVER FOUND.
TO THIS DAY, INVESTIGATORS HAVE
NO IDEA WHAT HAPPENED TO JAZZY.
>> WOW.
PETER, THAT IS SURELY A STORY A
LOT OF FOLKS ARE GOING TO WANT
TO SEE.
YOU CAN -- FIRST OF ALL, THANK
YOU.
AND YOU CAN CATCH PETER'S REPORT
"THE KILLING OF COWBOY RAY
GREEN" ON "48 HOURS" TOMORROW A